to be really honest i didn't realize how
serious it was
on ground level because until you've
actually been in here yeah you don't
know
michael feels lucky to be alive he's
just out of critical care
and a fortnight in hospital has taken
its toll
but when issue we're experiencing it
it's a different matter
and you are very very frightened
michael's fully vaccinated his booster
invite arrived the day he was admitted
sorry
in the next bed is adam he spent his
37th birthday in intensive care
never had that feeling of suffocation
but just fighting
just to breathe on the ground
unvaccinated he says he'd be meaning to
book a jab
i don't know if i was on my deathbed but
i certainly felt like it
[Music]
if
the jobs the vaccine reduces
i see you
reducing what i've been through
then it needs to be taken
dr manavas run the kovid ward at the
royal preston throughout the pandemic
a few weeks ago he had 27 patients
now there are more than 50.
every time i leave the hospital after
seeing these patients
to be honest i'm shocked to see in
various places like supermarkets people
not wearing masks in that group of
patients who deteriorate and require
critical care admission
vast majorities still are
unvaccinated or have received only a
single dose of the vaccine
but covid is causing other problems on
the ward look at these six empty beds
they're in the green zone meant for
seriously ill respiratory patients who
don't have covid but someone tested
positive so patience can't be admitted
so much pressure with regard to beds and
particularly green respiratory beds and
non-covered respiratory beds but we
helpless we can't do anything about our
hands are tied we can't bring them in
it's deeply frustrating for patients and
staff they've coped with covert for
months but the job feels never-ending
we've had staff who've
suffered with ptsd and trust who still
aren't back at work they've seen some
horrific horrific
um
deaths for our patients you know and
it's it's as a result as a consequence
of that they've developed ptsd in their
own right hardly surprising they've lost
over 800 patients here and that number
continues to creep up
you spend time on these wards and all
these full bays are a pretty bleak
reminder we might feel more relaxed
outside but in here it's anything but in
fact it's absolutely relentless
staff are managing but only just and
with admissions increasing they're worn
out and worrying what winter will bring
laura bundock sky news preston